by the age of 24 Hermann Goering was a
famous combat pilot a national hero and
leader of Germany's most celebrated
fighter squadron by the time of his
death less than 30 years later he was
reviled as a monster with the blood of
millions on his hands highly decorated
combat pilot drug-addicted lunatic
international statesman and one of the
20th century's most notorious criminals
Hurons life was one of soaring highs and
crashing lows and in the biographic Co
this week we explore the life of this
man the young Hermann Goering enjoyed a
privileged upbringing his own mother and
father had little money but his Jewish
Godfather dr. Hermann Epstein was
fabulously wealthy and he welcomed the
goings to live at one of his two castles
this apparent act of altruism was no
doubt influenced by the fact that
Epstein was having an affair with
Goering smother if Hermann was aware of
this then he didn't seem to mind the two
became close with Epstein encouraging
Hammond in his love of hunting climbing
and adventure when Goering develops an
interest in all things military it was
again his Jewish Godfather who pulled
some strings to have the boy enrolls at
the prestigious military academy at
Karlsruhe in 1914 the great European
powers went to war
Goering was by then 21 years old and
serving in an infantry regiment but
sensing there would be better
opportunities for glory elsewhere he
applied to join the Imperial German
flying Corps Goering began his new
career as an observer but when the
opportunity arose to get behind the
controls he seized it with both hands he
proved to be a natural flier and thanks
to the countless hours he'd spent
hunting he was already a lethal marksman
this was a deadly combination for an
aspiring combat pilot by October 1915
Goering was newly qualified and hungry
for glory he only had to wait a little
over a month before he scored his first
kill them by June 1916 his tally had
risen to 3 a few professions in history
have ever been quite as dangerous as a
World War 1 pilots and in November 1916
he was shot down for the firm
first and only time accounts of the
incidents are sketchy and contradictory
but there's no doubt that Goering did
suffer an injury that kept him out of
action for several months on returning
to duties he began to rack up kills an
impressive race he rose through the
ranks of aces winning numerous awards
for bravery and his fame began to grow
his face was printed on collectible
matchboxes newspapers and magazines
featured articles on him and everywhere
he went people treated him like a
celebrity
Goering he adored the attention in April
19 the Germans suffered a major blow
when their greatest pilot Manfred von
Richthofen better known to history as
the Red Baron was shot down and killed
writ often had been commander of an
elite squadron made up of Germany's
finest Airmen it was assumed that his
replacement would be drawn from their
ranks since the likes of Ernest Odette
and worth of on Rick 7 the Red Baron's
brother were considered the most likely
candidates but as it turned out it was
actually Hermann Goering who landed the
job this came as something of a surprise
Goering he hasn't been part of the
Richthofen squadron and he was still
some way off the top of the charts in
terms of kills
however Goering had skill he had charm
and he seemed to be a natural leader
Goering took charge of the Richthofen
squadron at a difficult time the balance
of power in the air had swung back and
forth through the war but now the Allies
were firmly in the ascendancy German
aircraft production couldn't keep up
with the British and French factories
attrition and exhaustion were taking
their toll on German pilots as well the
situation on the grounds it was equally
desperate
shortly before Gehrig's promotion the
United States of America had declared
war on Germany a huge offensive designed
to knock France out of the war before
American troops arrived in any great
numbers failed Germany sued for peace
and the armistice came into effect on
the 11th of November 1918 garin's last
orders were to lead his squadron to a
French airfield where their aircraft
would be handed over to the Allies in a
tearful final speech to his men he
predicted our time will come again
[Music]
garin's exploits made him a household
name but he missed the excitement that
the war had provided recruiting for
other pilots from amongst his wartime
comrades II put on a series of highly
dangerous acrobatic shows dazzling of
thousands of onlookers with his daring
stunt flying when the public began to
lose their appetite for this sort of
spectacle he took on a more modest job
flying charter planes it was during this
time that he met the love of his life
countess karin von fork was sickly and
frail and already married but she was
also wealthy and beautiful for Goering
it was love at first sight Karin she
felt the same way about the dashing
eminent in 1922 she abandoned her
husband and a child to make a new life
with Goering in Munich it was here that
the couple first encountered Adolphe
Hitler at this point in history Hitler
was still something of a nonentity a
rabble rousing demagogue with little
real power or influence karin however
she was entranced and she was determined
to form an alliance between Goering and
this foster II and corporal Goering
willingly bound his fate to that of a
Dolf Hitler ins in November of 1923 he
joined his master in a plot to overthrow
the government
2,000 Nazis with Hitler and Goering
side-by-side in the front rank marched
on the Bavarian war ministry Hitler
believed the police would not oppose
them but he underestimated their resolve
they opened fire and Hitler fell or by
some accounts flared while Goering was
badly wounded by a bullet to his thigh
Hitler and his conspirators they were
now wanted criminals and this was a
particularly difficult situation for
Goering since he was one of the most
recognizable faces in all of Germany
well Hilla was arrested
Goering chose to flee having received
treatment from ironically enough a
Jewish doctor Goering and carrying
across the Austrian border the next two
years would be the most miserable of
gearing's life Garen's wound became
badly infected and in Austria he was
given injections of morphine to ease the
pain this was the beginning of an
addiction that would almost cost Goering
his sanity and even his life
the once athletic ace pilots waited
balloons Karin sold most of her
possessions to fund gearing's habit and
his wild mood swings
after fearing for her life faced with
the very real possibility of Lou
in Karen earring agreed to enter into a
withdraw program during the Great War
the first battle of Gehrig's life he had
fought for his country for personal
glory and for prestige his second great
struggle against morphine addiction had
none of that glamour it was a fight II
very nearly lost he screamed at his
nurses that he wanted to meet death and
even attempted to physically attack them
for his own safety and the safety of
everyone around him he was forced into a
straitjacket and confined to a padded
cell to karyn's relief Goering emerged
from the depths of his own personal hell
and he was discharged from the asylum in
October of 1925 less than a year
afterwards the German government granted
him an amnesty absolving him of his
crimes he was free to return home and to
resume his service to a doff Hitler who
had been himself released after just
nine months in prison having failed to
gain control of Germany by force Hitler
instead attempted to seize power through
the ballot box in order to accomplish
this he needed a wealthy backers to
embrace the nationalist socialist cause
Hitler was a brilliant public speaker
capable of whipping crowds into a frenzy
but in more intimate social settings he
was awkward and uncomfortable most of
the other senior Nazis were
unsophisticated thugs only Goering was
entirely at home wining and dining
German society's elites Goering threw
himself into his new role with huge
energy and commitments but his beloved
Karen's health was by now seriously
deteriorating in October of 1931 she
collapsed and died leaving Goering
distraught he would later commissioned
the building of a huge country residence
sets in 40,000 hectares of woodlands
naming it Karen Hall in her memory
in January of 1933 Hitler succeeded in
maneuvering himself into the position of
Chancellor of Germany
Goering reward for his years of service
was to the appointed Prussian Minister
of the Interior through his ministerial
salary corruption and bribes he found
the means to fund a lifestyle that was
becoming opulent to the point of
absurdity to go along with his mansions
his exotic pets and his increasingly
ostentatious uniforms Goering he also
held real political power his first step
was to notify the police
sacking 22 police chiefs and replacing
them with men sympathy
National Socialism with the police's
loyalty assured he ordered them to crush
subversive elements in society which in
practice meant Jews and communists
Goering made no attempt distance himself
from these killings he stated every
bullet fired from the barrels of a
police pistol is my bullet if you call
that murder than I am a murderer
everything has been ordered by me
the biggest threat to Hitler however did
not come from the Communists but from
within the Nazi Party itself the thugs
of the SA the Nazi party's own
paramilitary army had been useful to
Hitler in his rise to power but there
become a bit of a problem Hitler wanted
the SA to be broken up but it's
commander Ernst röhm openly defied him
the men of the SA they were loyal to
Rama if he attempted an armed coup he
might just succeed in toppling Hitler
Goering who hated Romans recognized a
very real threat to his own power he
urged his Fuehrer act and reluctantly
Hitler agreed On June the 30th 1934 the
night of the Long Knives began it was
time for Hitler to settle some old
scores and strom was arrested and shot
as were dozens of those who had angered
or obstructed Hitler in one way or the
other much of the planning had been
entrusted to Goering who executed the
operation with great skill and a
complete lack of moral scruples Hitler's
position within the party it had now
become unassailable but he was already
looking forward to the day when he could
attack Germany's neighbours and avenge a
defeat in the great war Germany was
banned from building an Air Force under
the terms of the Treaty of Versailles so
Goering was tasked with building it up
in secret the Germans have been
preparing for the day when their Air
Force would rise once again since long
before the days of Hitler coming to
power while Germans were barred from
developing military aircraft the ban on
civilian aircraft had been lifted in
1922 since then the German aviation
industry had produced numerous fast mail
carrying planes that could easily be
converted into fighters and airliners
that could be converted into bombers
Lufthansa Germany's state-owned airline
which was formed in 1926 would provide
many of the pilots for Goering x'
fledgling Luftwaffe showered with lavish
funds ngering fledgling Luftwaffe grew
quickly
in March over 1935 its existence was
officially announced to the world
over the next four years the Luftwaffe
would receive four times as much
investment as Britain's RF and more than
ten times that of Frances air force
unlike the Allied air forces it was
designed specifically to operate in
support of Germany's ground forces the
world-class Messerschmitt 109 became
operational in 1937 and it forms the
backbone of the Luftwaffe fighter force
the Junkers Ju 87 Stuka dive-bomber a
machine for which neither the British
and all the French at any direct
equivalent would provide support for
Germany's fast moving armored spearheads
as Goering later told his captains in
1945 we armed Germany until we bristled
Goering didn't entirely share Hitler's
enthusiasm for war and this wasn't due
to any sense of compassion for the
millions who were died but simply
because he had too much to lose his time
was spent mixing with high society
indulging his passions for hunting and
collecting art and expanding his own
personal Empire within the Reich
unlike Hitler he didn't see himself as
being on some sort of quasi divine
mission to restore German greatness
he simply pursued a political career
because it brought him personal power
and enormous wealth where Hitler thought
victory was inevitable
Goering knew it wasn't and feared he
might find himself on the losing side
despite the reservations of many of us
generals Hitler chose war and on the 1st
of September 1939 Germany invaded Poland
the Luftwaffe was at this time the most
powerful Air Force in the world its
commander-in-chief however was largely
untested as a military commander in
World War one he had spent a few months
in command of a single squadron but that
was a very different matter
to directing operations of an entire Air
Force in a very modern war while Goering
possessed the intelligence and
ruthlessness of a great military
commander he would fail miserably in the
role this was at least in part because
the corpulence Goering had far too much
on his plate in addition to being the
Luftwaffe commander-in-chief he was also
responsible for civilian and military
aviation policy the Reich's
anti-aircraft defences industrial and
economic policy and a good deal more
than that these responsibilities were
far too much for any one man
particularly one who was once again
sliding into drug addiction in 1937
Goering had been prescribed the pain
Percodan a morphine derivative to treat
a severe toothache the toothache
eventually went away but Goering kept on
taking the drugs as the war turned
against Germany Goering continued to up
his dosage his drug use compounded his
weaknesses as a military leader his
continual overestimation of the
Luftwaffe escape abilities his tendency
to retreat from reality rather than face
up to bad news and a desire to please
Hitler which repeatedly led to him
making promises the Luftwaffe could not
keep sometimes with catastrophic results
Gehrig's fading capabilities were not
immediately apparent in the attack on
Poland's the Luftwaffe made short work
of the Polish Air Force and its obsolete
machines in 1940 it was Frances turn and
the Luftwaffe once again dominated the
skies as German tanks emerged from the
supposedly impossible Ardenne forests
threatening to encircle the best of the
French and British divisions as the
British prepared to evacuate their army
from the continent the German armored
spearheads were in position to sweep
into Dunkirk and deal what might have
been pay death blow to the British
Expeditionary Force Goering however
persuaded Hitler that his Luftwaffe
could finish the job on its own the
German tanks were halted in the
Luftwaffe hit the British with
everything they had the limits of what
air power could and could not achieve
had not yet been established and nobody
had ever attempted to destroy an army
from the air if Goering had have given
the matter sufficient forty might not
have been so confident
the vast artillery bombardments of World
War one were not enough to win battles
without support and the Luftwaffe
couldn't come close to matching that
kind of hitting power
Goering 'he's most proved hollow and a
huge Armada of ships plaque to the
British Expeditionary Force to safety
across the English Channel with the
British having fled the continents in
the French signing an armistice on the
22nd of June 1940 Hitler was amused and
enraged to discover that Britain had no
intention of giving up the fight he
began planning an invasion but
stipulated that it couldn't go ahead
until Britain's Royal Air Force had been
destroyed as an effective fighting force
once again Goering was on hand to assure
Hitler that his Luftwaffe would make
short work of the RAF he believed the
Luftwaffe to be superior in every
respects but this simply wasn't the case
the British had roughly the same number
of fighters as the Luftwaffe and their
supermarine spitfires were every bit as
good as the German any 109s Britain also
had the advantage for a d'harans a
sophisticated ground control system and
thanks to Goering zin ability to get the
most out of the German economy British
factories were producing more fighter
aircraft per month than the entire Reich
Goering also believed himself to be on
the brink of victory throughout the
Battle of Britain but he never came as
close as he imagined Garen's third big
mistake if the war and almost certainly
his most calamitous came in the wake of
Hitler's ill-judged invasion of the
Soviet Union when the 6th army became
encircled at Stalingrad it's only hope
was to attempt any media break out
Hitler hated the idea of retreat under
any circumstances so when Goering
claimed the trapped army could be
supplied from the air the Fuehrer seized
upon the suggestion the idea was dead
all nonsense caring staff knew it and
Goering really should have known it too
the results who was the complete
destruction of the 6th army and
Stalingrad became the turning point of
world war two so at this point Hitler no
longer trusted Goering and the Luftwaffe
Chiefs reputation it plunged new lows as
the Allied bombing campaign
systematically destroyed German cities
Goering now did his best to stay out of
Hitler's way rather than attend to his
many responsibilities he spent the bulk
of his time hunting at Karen Hall
plundering Europe for works of art to
add to his enormous collection and
consuming ever greater quantities of
drugs
[Music]
on April the 30th 1945 Hitler committed
suicide with the Reich collapsing all
around Zim Goering knew that the war was
lost
unlike most other top Nazis who either
killed themselves or attempted to flee
Goering seemed to be under the bizarre
impression that he hadn't done much
wrong and therefore had little to fear
on May the 9th he surrendered himself to
the Americans along with 20,000
painkillers and one of the world's
largest art collections most of it
looted from all across Europe Goering
had expected an audience with Eisenhower
instead he was accused of crimes against
humanity and waging wars of aggression
his guilt or innocence of these charges
would be decided at trial while the
prosecution prepared their case Goering
was weaned off his drug addiction and
placed on a strict diet the result was
that the much diminished Goering who had
blundered his way through the war was
now restored to the cunning manipulative
force of old of the 21 leading Nazis on
trial at Nuremberg Goering was the most
senior he didn't expect to escape the
death penalty but he did intend to go
down fighting in one early exchange he
ranked so many rings around the
prosecutor that the American threw down
his headphones and refused to continue
with the cross-examination Garren's
argument was that he hadn't wanted war
and didn't work to avoid it when forced
to fight through circumstances outside
of his control he had done so with the
principles of a noble Teutonic Knight it
was not in his nature to harm women or
children and he had known nothing of the
Holocaust given his powers of
self-delusion he may well have convinced
himself that this was true whatever the
case it was enjoying being center stage
again at least until he was presented
with evidence that shattered this image
of himself as a noble warrior the idea
that Goering could have known nothing of
the Holocaust was absurd but there was
little documentary evidence to link him
directly to it
however there were plenty of documents
indicating that he had participated in
the persecution of Jews and personally
profited from it not only that but tens
of thousands of slave laborers had
toiled and died in the Luftwaffe
factories and under garin's leadership
the Luftwaffe had conducted horrific and
often lethal experiments on Jews ships
and prisoners of war it buns in Europe
for works of art ordered prisoners to be
shortened at Allied airmen lynched the
judge found Goering guilty on all
charges and passed down a sentence of
death by hanging
Goering objected he was a soldier and as
such he should be executed by firing
squad
rather than hanged like a common
criminal when his demand was refused
Goering took matters into his own hands
on October the 15th he bit down on a
cyanide capsule quiet hour Goering
obtained this cyanide capsule is still
not known for sure his suicide note
explained that he felt no obligation to
submit to his enemies justice while
awaiting trial he had told psychologists
that within fifty years there would be a
statue of him in every German town
going's opinion of himself had not been
dented at all by defeat but his
judgement of his place in history
certainly well wide of the mark
his exploits as a brave fighter pilot
have been utterly eclipsed by his crimes
few men have ever trashed their
reputation quite so comprehensively as
Hermann Goering so I really hope you
found that video interesting if you did
please do give us a thumbs up below and
don't forget to subscribe we've got
brand new videos like this three times a
week so hit that subscribe button and
you will learn all about those when they
come out especially if you hit the bell
because the subscribe button doesn't do
what it used to and as always thank you
for watching
[Music]